josée legault alec castonguay luc
ferrandez bonsoir
alors hier cette sortie hier soir tous
étaient rivés à nos téléphones docteur
arruda qui partent à démissionner je
vous fais entend tout de suite et ça va
lancer notre discussion monsieur legault
il a revu il ya repris cette formule à
plusieurs reprises dans la conférence de
presse il ya davantage davantage plus
d'avantagés que d'inconvénients
avoir quelqu'un nouveau assène formule
qu'on avait concocté on est comme
dieu fait un excellent travail pendant
les 22 mots je pense que il ya des
avantages et des désavantages à changer
de personnes mais à partir du moment où
on en a discuté puisque il convenu qu'il
y avait peut-être plus davantage d'être
des avantages mais on s'est mis d'accord
là dessus
à partir du moment où commence avec vous
josé où il a convenu il parle de
monsieur arruda qui a convenu donc
signifiante le premier ministre cheyrou
da donc ce n'est pas une émission soyons
clairs qui a été
lancé seul dans une chambre en disant je
dois partir là le bureau du premier
ministre a eu des contacts avec lui puis
l'a convaincu que c'est la mère josée
oui ben quoi consiste à peu près
impossible de savoir le contenu et le
vrai contenu des discussions ce sont des
discussions très privé aussi et puis ça
a était quoi aussi le jeu peut dire le
input du ministre de la santé et koster
dubé qui on le croyait on sentait son
agacement depuis des mois avec certaines
sorties du docteur arruda mais c'est
clair que c'est quelque chose qui a été
comme vous êtes bien préparée bien huilé
et pour des raisons dont on pourrait
discuter par là le panel mais pour des
raisons essentiellement
ça c'est essentiellement politique
est-ce que ça s'impose à georges
poursuivez vous rappeler parce que
c'était la chose à faire d'après
mais si on apprend des choses oui moi je
fais partie de ceux et celles qui est
pas seulement des chroniques amont de
plus en plus d'experts aussi qui se
disait vraiment très déçu lé de
plusieurs prises de position du docteur
arruda sur des questions fondamentales
dans la gestion de la pandémie puis je
parle pas juste du masque dans la
première vague depuis ça a vraiment
persister jusqu'à tout récemment où le
docteur avoue d'autres disaient que les
masques n95 était moins sécuritaire que
dès que des masques de procédure alors
que la science dit exactement le
contraire donc oui sur le fond des
choses je pense que ça tenait plus
depuis longtemps mais le premier
ministre a surtout entre les mains
depuis quelques mois des sondages qui
montrent et le léger d'aujourd'hui le
confirme qu' à un glissement d'un
glissement la confiance de la population
envers sa gestion de la pandémie
et comme monsieur harouna il est aussi
associée étroitement et bien sûr vous
devez passer à la trappe alec comment
vous comprenez les dernières 24 heures
je pense que ça se permet depuis plus de
24 heures en fait qu'on ne fait envoyé
du côté du gouvernement des messages à
horacio arruda dès la fin novembre
il était peut-être dû pour prendre du
repos parce qu'ils travaillent 7 jours
sur 7 presque 16 heures par jour horacio
arruda depuis très longtemps et ont
commencé à juger puis une préoccupation
constante dans l'entourage du premier
ministre tous ceux qui travaillent sur
la gestion de la crise veut que ce soit
christian dubé ses conseillers les
conseillers de françois legault bon ça
demande beaucoup entre eux ce qui était
correct est ce que tu as besoin de repos
parce que c'est passé non plus de
travailler tout le temps peut demander
le jugement est affecté par la la la la
perte de sommeil le trop-plein de
travail que reçoit vous disent toujours
non non je suis correct je suis correct
puis acceptée à peu près des côtes et
qu'on lui demandait quelque chose pour
aider l'union tings là peu importe
l'ordre du jour de la nuit est acceptée
dès la fin du mois novembre on a trouvé
que ça commençait à être décousu autant
privé qu'en public le certaines
explications c'est plus compliqué de
justifier certaines mesures
on avait de la difficulté à suivre
horacio arruda josé par des masques n95
sur les tests rapides ça a pris beaucoup
de temps avec le québec 10 bat on devra
utiliser davantage les
d'entendre l on a mal préparé la vague
ou micron reçu un coup d'oeil sur les
kids à on a suffisamment de suffisamment
de protection vaccinale parce qu'on a
donné des deuxièmes doses espacées par
rapport aux premières alors que dans le
fond on aurait pu commencer plus vite la
dose de rappel dont on lui suggérait
tombe un peu plus de temps pour lui pour
être pour se concentrer sur ses idées
pour être capable d'avoir des opinions
qui sont un peu plus éclairés puis il
refusait de le faire puis on l'a un peu
je pense l'expression trop forte mais
mis au pied du mur au début du mois de
janvier quand les revenus de la pause
jour de la le 3 janvier une discussion
au lieu où on a dit au ratio est
vraiment besoin de temps pour toi parce
que ça nuit au conseil que tu donnes et
soit le choix ou bien tu quittes ou bien
tu prends un mois congé pote trois
semaines pour deux semaines dans un mois
de congé peut être placé par marie
france rennes on entretient surviendra
reposer et l'italie en réflexion il
parlait avec sa conjointe entre autres
en fin de semaine il a un deal et arrive
en disant je peux prendre un mois de
congé en pleine vague comme ça ça paraît
très mal je pense que je suis mieux de
quitter et on a accepté sa démission bon
l'udc est ce que pour la population à ce
que vous vous sentiez autour de vous un
indice à peut-être pas désaveu mais les
gens commencent à être agacé ou le
suivaient plus difficilement
oui absolument mais des directeurs de la
santé publique qui ont fait des erreurs
d'appréciation de jugement à travers le
monde il y en a pas un qui est blanc
comme neige dans le coffre à outils a
fait des erreurs aux états unis là il
voulait pas été remplacés pour autant
programmation haruno disais au début de
la pandémie le masque c'est peut-être
pas idéal fois uci disait la même chose
professeur extrêmement une réputation
impeccable que vécut plusieurs crises
l'instant la sorte est donc en suède on
le vus il ya des erreurs parce que il ya
du nouveau mais le processus pour
s'assurer qu'ils aient pas d'erreur
c'est pas d'envoyer quelqu'un sera posée
ou de le renvoyer c'est de faire de la
santé publique un forum de discussion
intègre et indépendant si la santé
publique par exemple avait eu sa propre
cellule de crise avait consulté au
quotidien ensemble de professeurs
universitaires et des deux médecins
portant dans les systèmes d'eau dans les
autres montréal est et québécois je veux
dire s'ils avaient eu ce le nombre
d'erreurs aurait été réduit et et mais
c'est pas ça que c'est passé comme le
fait comme l'a signalé précédemment dans
le monde on pardon sur un tweet hier
monsieur harouna faisait partie d'une
équipe de 15 personnes dont il était le
seul représentant de la santé publique
et les discussions se prenaient part
cette équipe cette cellule d'urgence là
parce que c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas
juste des questions de santé publique
quand on prend une décision quant à
prendre dix ont fermé une route ou de
fermer les bars et pas juste de la santé
publique il ya aussi de l'économie aussi
le moral de la population etc mais il
était le seul et isolé alors c'est
facile à ce moment là de commettre des
erreurs quand il constamment sur le spot
s'il avait été au sein d'une équipe
qu'on aurait qui aurait envoyé ses
recommandations après étude et après
consultation il y aurait eu moins
d'erreurs est ce que c'est le moment
alors que monsieur boileau arrive le
docteur boyrie de changer les règles du
jeu josé parce que les gars se débat
depuis le début est-ce qu'on devrait pas
séparer davantage que les
recommandations de la santé publique
soient exposés plus clairement et que
les décisions politiques qui seront
toujours ultime soit elle aussi séparés
qui a pas des points de presse collé
comme ça est-ce que c'est mama pas
changé
mais c'est à dire car quand pète
pourrait pour une ou un directeur de la
santé publique à part peut-être pas des
mix à requiert au moins deux choses
fondamentales
oui la dépendance politique mais aussi
la compétence et moi je regrette mais je
pense que monsieur avoue doit démontrer
encore une fois pas pour la première
vague on peut pardonner beaucoup de
choses à la première vague mais des
erreurs qui se sont répétées répéter
répéter depuis des erreurs graves qui
ont la main d informer la population sur
des moyens quand même à ses fondamentaux
se protéger inclus à la contagion par
est grosso la ventilation etc donc ça
prend les deux parce que y attendent aux
provinces par exemple en
colombie-britannique
l'adapteur légal et indépendante
politiquement elle était vraiment
applaudi pour sa gestion de la première
vague mais dernièrement elle est très
critique et donc dire comme eu un
glissement de compétences aussi est-ce
que c'est l'usure la fatigue dans son
coach je sais pas trop
mais en fait c'est donc ça prend lui 2
et à choisir entre l'indépendance
politique et la compétence de ce général
là parce que si ça reste un général en
pandémie je prendrai la compétence mais
si on peut avoir les deux évidemment ce
serait encore mieux je reprends aussi
l'idée d'abréger iev qui est un
chercheur en immunologie quand même
renommé qui équipe plusieurs jours
suggéré aussi écouter la constitution de
comités aviseurs est dépendant avec des
spécialistes n'a donc vraiment le
indépendant du pouvoir politique pourra
viser non seulement le premier ministre
mais le ministre de la santé mais là
aussi le premier ministre continue à
refuser ça une fois que monsieur à
coulogne plus dans le portrait mais s'il
ya d'autres problèmes dans la gestion de
la pandémie est là il n'y aura plus
personne d'autre qu'on était qu'il
allait qu'est ce que c'est le moment
d'envisager des changements
d'organigrammes de de créer une distance
entre la santé publique et le ministère
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ce que
lui disait savoir qu'il ya pas d pas
beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde qui
ont été les responsables et il ya
beaucoup d'endroits où on une séparation
entre donc l'expérience santé publique
et le gouvernement et sa part
nécessairement mieux performer pas juste
aux états unis la troisième vague en
ontario était une catastrophe pourtant
fonctionne avec un comité indépendant en
alberta c'est extrêmement celle aussi
josé parler de la colombie britannique
chaque vague est différente d'une
province à l'autre
est-ce que l'indépendance donnerait
quelque chose de plus ou peut-être
peut-être pas moi je suis plus ou moins
incertain de ça ça donne un pouvoir au
contraire d'être très tiendrait du
premier ministre pour qu'on soit capable
justement dans la cellule de crise et
d'influencer les décisions du premier
ministre plutôt que de faire des
conférences s'est pas exposé qu'on peut
pas améliorer les choses du de deux
choses que je pense peuvent être faits
je suis d'accord avec andré veillette
josy bien de citer près par le premier
ministre mais certainement que le
nouveau directeur national de la santé
publique et au comité un peu plus large
on reçoit ou de travailler beaucoup avec
sa petite équipe richard massé eric
litvak les deux ont quitté d'ailleurs
cet automne ce que contribuer à je pense
des boues chaulées un peu reçu à roudet
qui avait une nouvelle angoisse mais
d'élargir l'entourage un peu de de luc
boileau d'avoir donc un avis extérieur
d'avoir un comité différent pour les
délits qu'on ait des pays séances
techniques d'information car il est
grosse annonce qu'ils soient menées par
la santé publique par des experts avant
la conférence de presse pour qu'on
puisse poser des questions plus
techniques une conférence de presse en
faisant entendre un extrait ici johanna
luz en conclure rapidement oui mais
aussi que le directeur de la santé
publique
rencontre les partis d'opposition il
doit informer aussi les partis
d'opposition de ces avis de ses conseils
etc ça ne peut pas continuer non plus à
rester en vasco comme comme ça y est
depuis le début bon ben vous allez voir
on reste un peu sur le même sujet parce
que l'une des auditions important qui
touche beaucoup de parents les écoles
écoutez bien le prochain extrait parce
que là c'est le même sujet de
l'indépendance même si on parle des
écoles et je reviens tout de suite afin
que je l' ai toujours dit puis je les
dis clairement ou nouveau directeur
national ça reste ma priorité le retour
avec moi j'ai su que cette fonction ne
doit être indépendante et
dans l'exercice que j'anticipe faire
elles le seront
alors moi j'ai trouvé ça révélateur le
jeu commence avec vous il dit je les dis
au nouveau directeur de la santé
publique le j'ai fait savoir à quel
point c'est important pour moi le
premier ministre que les écoles ouvrent
lundi matin lui il d'un livre il doit
faire son avis jeudi lens que c'est une
bonne idée ou pas d'ouvrir les écoles
gosses en attendant le
tout à fait c'est drôle parce que je
m'en allais justement parler de ça bon
c'est pas juste le veulent il n'y a pas
d'organisation idéal faut tenir compte
aussi de la personnalité du premier
ministre et la prostate par s'arrêter de
monsieur legault c'est de décider et
après de consulter il dit dans la phrase
moi je veux ça oui on va consulter
monsieur voyons bien sûr on va pour
sauter mais moi je veux soit par exemple
alors il le fait avec avec noël rappelez
vous la décision de la santé publique
devait arriver le 6 décembre lui le 1er
décembre dit moi j'aimerais bien avoir
20 personnes assises à table auto à noël
et après consulte la santé publique en
demandant est ce que c'est possible
la santé public acquiesce alors on voit
le processus en place aux voix la salle
est-ce que sainté révélateur parce que
bien sûr qu'en bout de ligne c'est le
gouvernement qui va décider c'est cette
personne ne remet pas en question mais
pons mais est ce que ça ne tente pas
l'addition qui va arriver de boileau
d'entendre ça alors qu'il était à un
mètre de l'huile ou deux mètres dont
20000 moi je pense que ça peut avoir
effectivement une influence en même
temps on a élu un gouvernement qui prend
des décisions et c'est lui qui va être
jugé sur la gestion sa part émis moi
j'ai compris surtout que ça envoie un
message à le goual haut en dix ans la
star toujours terre soit une grande
révélation as a toujours été la priorité
au québec de garder les écoles plus
ouverte françois legault ça en faisant
on a gardé nos écoles plus ouverte qu
ailleurs depuis le début de cette
pandémie là et le devoir l'ontario la
colombie britannique et l'alberta ouvrir
leur école ça doit le démanger un petit
peu ceci dit ça me pose est que le bois
l'eau et son équipe sont obligés d'abord
de diable s'allumant winamp le sait que
des manières peut-être de rouvrir les
écoles de manière plus sécuritaire avec
des protocoles différents ou là les
experts la santé publique aux bons nos
priorités du gouvernement s'est gardé
les émissions décapage oui maintenant si
l'on est capable est ce qu'on peut
améliorer les choses
il faut se plier à la personnalité de
boileau on ne connaît pas beaucoup on va
voir à quel point ce serait bien en même
temps c'est normal qu'ils souhaitent
changer parce que la taxe sur les
non-vaccinés je veux beaucoup de gens
interrogés
oui mais c'est parce que le piège c'est
le même aussi depuis depuis plusieurs
mois c'est à dire que le premier
ministre dit d'un côté je suis celui qui
décide et c'est tout à fait normal c'est
lui qui est élu c'est lui qui était
imputable à la population et en même
temps je suis toujours des
recommandations de la santé
alors c'est tant que le premier ministre
lui même a pas d mélissa propres
contradictions et ce sans tenir tout
simplement ah oui je prends les conseils
de la santé publique mais je suis le
dernier à prendre des décisions et voici
pourquoi points
ben c'est sûr que même d'accord l'étoile
tour de table taxe pour les non vaccinés
ce une bonne idée ou pas l'udc j'aurais
préféré une obligation de vaccins
vaccinale la taxe alors toutes sortes de
défaut bon premièrement il faut dire que
ça satisfait beaucoup de monde parce que
enfin on se dit bon ben on est tous pris
dans l'embouteillage pour une voiture
qui passe sur la voie d'accotement à
droite à fond puis elle s'en va créer
plus d'embouteillages plus loin on est
tous fâchés sont en confiance mais dans
les hôpitaux parce qu'on a vu plusieurs
exemples de ce genre de baroudeur le chp
à maxi début je m'en fous mais
finalement c'est lui qui finit par créer
le problème mais dans les hôpitaux la
situation est bien différente les
médecins travaillent c'est pas tout le
temps ce personnage là qu'il n'est pas
vaccinée c'est aussi des itinérants des
personnes avec des déficiences des
personnes âgées esseulées qui
comprennent pas tous des migrants
récents qui ne savent pas que c'est à la
fois gratuit universel lieu de tout dans
la société qui ce qu'ils se ramassent à
l'hôpital pour ces gens là je suis pas
certain que une contribution financière
par exemple ok alec je vous prends je
suis désolé alec là dessus
ce qui peut sembler attrayante mais qui
est quand même compliquée et je peux
répéter ce que le cac vivendi parce que
c'est tout à fait vrai j'ajoute et ceux
qui ont des moyens financiers assez
faible pour qui un 500 mails ou 2000 $
c'est de l'argent que tu peux pas mettre
dans la nourriture de qualité où je peux
pas inscrits et enfants ont ce pas un
peu je peux dire qui je peux me plaindre
ceux qui sont pas vaccinés le je pense
que c'est de leur faute mais c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué dans la
réalité même si c'est populaire est ce
que ces jeux légalement possible je
pense que oui 10 avenue pour le faire
mais ça certains dans les détails il
faudra que ce soit très bien je me
chercher pour que j'ouvre un handicap
jeunes avenue intéressante - écoutez je
suis pour la vaccination obligatoire la
loi sur la santé publique le permet je
pense qu'on en est rendu là et on est
plusieurs au québec chez des experts
aussi les aciers ministre a le passé on
ne peut pas dire aux personnes c'est
votre choix de vous faire vacciner ou
non puis en même temps on va vous taxer
après si vous l'êtes pas et que vous
utilisez le système de santé c'est aussi
vous êtes ce serait plus cohérent
effectivement que de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire plus simple que
d'essayer par la porte arrière le faire
très bien merci à vous trois merci je
suis désolé s'est terminée à la merci
bonsoir voir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit